TO GET THE COMMITTEE STARTED
BUT I WANT TO WARN YOU IN
ADVANCE AND BECAUSE WE ONLY HAD
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF BILLS WE
TOLD ALL THE WITNESSES THEY
WOULD BE IN A PARTICULAR- IN A
PARTICULAR SEQUENCE I'M NOT
CHANGED THE ONES OF THE MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BIT OF A OF A HICK
UP BUT THAT WILL JUST GET HIS
BILL IF THAT'S- YEAH YEAH JUST
LIKE. WHEN IN. DESTRUCTIVE TO
READ TO COME. SOME MATERIALS
ALL. IT INSTEAD TODAY- SO THAT
I'M PRECISE TO WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY GUIDELINES REQUIRING
US TO DO- FOR FIGURE AFTERNOON
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
ON COMMUNICATIONS CONVEYANCE
AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND JUST
READ IT SO THAT I MISSED. DON'T
MISS ANYTHING. I WELCOME THE
MEMBERS TO BEGIN WE WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF OF RETURN.
THE CAPITAL AND TO HEAR THAT
THE- KING HERE. AVAILABLE IN
BEING ABLE TO HEAR BILLS IS
INCLUDES ARE SIMPLY RULES-
START. ARMS THE LEGISLATIVE.
THE CENTER. THAT WAS TO. IT'S
BEEN. TO THAT END WE WANT TO GO
IF YOU KNOW TO LOGISTICS ABOUT
TODAY HEARING WITH POP
PARTICIPATION HELP PRESERVE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS
DISCUSSION DUE TO THE CURRENT
STATE HOME ORDER WERE PRACTICES
SOCIAL JUSTICE IN HERE I AM ONE
OF THE HEARING- HERE IN THE ON
THE FLOOR AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. THE ROLE OF.
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. WHO CAN WALK TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARINGS- IN
PERSON. ARE WE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TODAY WILL PROVIDING TESTIMONY.
SO FOR A FIRST FOR THE PEOPLE
HERE- IN THE ROOM. I HAVE TO
MAINTAIN- PHYSICAL DISTANCE- IF
YOU'RE HERE WITHIN SIX FEET OF
THE NEXT PERSON- IN THIS SPACE
WE ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS- IN
A MINIMAL CONTINGENCY OF STAFF
IN A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN AGAIN SIX FEET- A
DISTANCE. THERE'SALSO STRIPPED
OF PHYSICAL DISTANCING PRODUCT
UP FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL IF YOU'VE
ENTERED OR LEFT. I DO THIS FOR
ANY OTHER HEARING. AT AND THOSE
WITH ME- AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY WHO ARE WE'RE GONNA MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS- DURING THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IF ANY MAN OF
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM LIKE THE
TEST OF BILL IS HANNAH ASK YOU
TO APPROACH MICROPHONE AGAIN
FOLLOWING ALL THE SAFETY
GUIDELINES. I WE WILL TO ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. ARE YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
DONE TEST TESTIFYING- OR TURN
YOUR SEATS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
GONNA USE WV ARE WITNESSING- IN
ADDITION TO THOSE WHO ARE ABLE
TO TESTIFY INSIDE OF THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE. OF ONE OF
OUR WITNESSING VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS- WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN- BEFORE ME SO
MEMBERS CAN WATER TESTIMONY
LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. AND WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO
ASK QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESSES.
ARE THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY
IN THE STREAM OF THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM- SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT. FOR CALLING
WITNESSES. LET ME THOSE ABUSING
THE PHONE- WE WILL YOU BE USING
A MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE NUMBER
WILL BE SHOWN ON THE SCREEN-
WHEN WE ARE SPEAKING- BUT JUST
SO THAT WE HAVE IT ON RECORD.
THE CALL IN NUMBER WILL BE. I
MEAN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE ALSO WE SHAUNA SCREEN. IS
TWO FOUR TWO SIX. TWO THREE
SEVEN A REPEAT THAT. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN A CALL IN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS AGAIN ON THE-
CNC COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON
YOUR- TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN A PLAN TO DO SO AS
THE AUTHOR OF IS THE BILL IS
BEGINNING TO TESTIFY AND I'LL
I'LL TRY REMIND EVERYBODY
BEFORE BILL THE CALL AND SO
YOU'RE IN THE KEEP. ARE THE
UPPER ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE EXT.
I IN ORDER BACK ON WITH YOU
SUPPORT POSE THE BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE LIMóN
TRACK AYE NOISES INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST YOUR SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE THE SOUND. WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO HEAR HERE IF
YOU'RE- NOT ON MUTE. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU THE MAIN
WITNESS PRYING TESTIMONY. OF
FOUR AGAINST THE BILL THE BILL
HE WILL YOU REMAIN ON A LIVE
LINE AND YOU'LL NEED TO PLEASE
MOVE YOUR PHONE TELL YOUR- CALL
TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE YOU CAN ALSO CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AND THAT IS THAT
NINE ONE SIX. YOU ONE NINE TWO
SIX THREE SEVEN SO AGAIN IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS ANY OF
THESE. TECHNOLOGIES YOU'RE
WELCOME TO CALL IN WILL FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO PLUG YOU AND
THAT'S NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE
NINE TWO SIX THREE SEVEN. AND
ALL THE STAFF THERE TO HELP
YOU. ALSO WANT TO MAKE A NOTE
THAT WERE EXCEPT IN WRITTEN
TESTIMONY FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
CANNOT PARTICIPATE ANY OF THE-
AND ANY OF THE METHODS NOW UP.
PROVIDED AND YOU CAN THAT INTO
THE LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. I THANK
YOU FOR VERY. IN IMPLEMENTING
SOME OF THESE. FROM THE STEPS.
AND WE WANT THANK YOU AND AT
THE MONEY APPLE RESPECTFUL.
PUBLIC AS WE'RE TRYING TO BE.
AND FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND WE'VE GONE
THROUGH A LOT BUT NONE THE LESS.
PLEASE NOTE THAT YOU HAVE MAKE
SURE IN THE CHAMBER THAT WILL
TURN ON AS THEY ARE RAISED SO
YOU NEED TO RAISE THEM AND- IF
YOU COULD STAND UP THAT WOULD
HELP. SO THAT THE- FOLKS ARE
HELPING US THE SERGEANTS. WOULD
BE ABLE TO TELL THAT YOU'RE
MIKE IS UP IN A YOU COULD
ACTUALLY GO AHEAD SPEAK
NORMALLY LIKE WE DO DURING.
DURING SESSION. THAT'S ABOUT IT
LET'S GIVE THE LET'S GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN. AND. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO THE- MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SANTIAGO HERE OBERNOLTE
BOERNER HORVATH. BONTA BRO KING.
IN ORDER GARCIA. HOLDEN
KAMLAGER. LOW PATTERSON. BUT
FILLED UP. RODRIGUEZ FORM OF
EXTRAPOLATION. THANKS AND
MISTER KING WILL BE A PLUS
REPLACING A MISS CERVANTES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU SIR
TING WE HAVE ONE BILL AD
CONSENT HOW WE WOULD NEED A-
FIRST AND A SECOND IN A BILL IS
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE. ONE
MORE TIME PLEASE. WE HAVE
MISTER ROUGH RIDE THE FIRST
INITIAL LTE IS SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WELCOME THANK
OUR AB AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO ON OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE ARE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI BONTA. BONTA
BROUGH. HI CAME. JANE OUR WATER
GARCIA. IN ORDER GARCIA HI
HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI HOME LONGER.
ON WATER ARE LOW. LOW TIME
PATTERSON. QUIRK SILVA. BUT
STILL BEHIND RODRIGUEZ. ELEVEN
ZERO BILL ABOUT. HI MR HERE
WOULD YOU MIND GOING AND WE'RE
GONNA CALL OUR FIRST YOU COULD
JUST DO A FROM IF NOBODY
OBJECTS HITTING A DEER FROM HIS
DESK- SERVERS HERE WOULD I
WOULD BE PRESENTING AB THIRTY
SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES A. B. THREE
ZERO SEVEN NINE IS THE
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM
DOESN'T CENTER PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES TELEFON TELEPHONIC
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE GRANDPA.
BECAUSE TO ME MEANS WITH THE
ONE'S CONTACTED MEDICAL
PROVIDERS. AND CONTINUE WITH
THEIR DAILY ROUTINE. AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN NINE SIX TO IMPROVE
THE DELIVERY AND ADMINISTRATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA WIRELESS
LIFELINE PROGRAM FOR LIFELINE
RECIPIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AS WE KNOW DURING HIS
COLBERT TEEN- CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
MANY PEOPLE HAVE. AND PUT OUT
OF WORK. APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MILLION INDIVIDUAL TO FALL.
CURRENT AS OF THAT WAS IT
ANNOUNCED THE- THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
FILED. PRIME INSURANCE. SINCE
THE OUTBREAK HERE AND CAL. NO
WERE PROTECTED HAVE AN ESTIMATE
ONE OUT OF FIVE CAL AND- AT
THIS PRO WILL ALLOW FOR INTO.
TO HAVE ACT. TO THE SERVICES
THAT THE STATE IS PROVIDING-
EVERYTHING FROM THE
UNEMPLOYMENT TO JOB SEEKING THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
MEDICAL SERVICES. THE LIST IS
LONG. AB THREE SEVEN THREE ZERO
SEVEN NINE REQUIRES THE CPC TO
THE CURRENT RESURFACING PROCESS
THAT ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO RE
APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM. USING AN
ELECTRONIC FOR TELEPHONE
ECCENTRIC EASE COMMON BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT RECIPIENTS FROM RE
APPLYING FOR THE PROGRAM. TO
ACCEPT NEW METHODS OF OUT OF
STATE ISSUED ID ASIAN FOR ALL
DOUBLE RELEASE INMATES IN
JUVENILES FOR PURPOSES OF
ENROLLMENT. AND EXIT AND THE
PROGRAM BASS QUALIFICATIONS FOR
ROMAN BUT AS LOW INCOME AUTO
INSURANCE PROGRAM'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BASS FIVE SISTERS
PROGRAM. TO ENSURE THE OPEN
NEED ASSISTANCE OUT OF TROUBLE
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS. THERE'S
ALSO A SIX MONTH PORTABILITY
FREEZE WITHIN THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE QUALITY AND
REDUCE THE RISK OF POSSIBLE
FRAUD. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK REVIVAL. AND WE WANT TO
REMIND THE- IF YOU'RE GOING TO
LINE UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
THAT THE NUMBER IS ON YOUR
SCREEN AND YOU SHOULD START
DIALING IN NOW. MAIN SUPPORT
WITNESSES. AND LET ME GO AHEAD
AND LIST- TO FOLKS TO SIMPLY
BECAUSE THIS IS UNUSUAL-
JESSICA BARTHOLOMEW AND CARLOS
BUCKET ON A WE CAN HAVE YOU
GUYS BEYOND THAT WILL GO TO
MAIN OPPOSITION WE START OFF
WITH THE SUPPORT. PLEASE THE
SHOULD BE ON OUR SCREEN OF A
BLUE FUND AFTER. TO GIVE US A
SECOND. I COULD IF THERE'S A
FIRST AND A SECOND WE CAN
ENTERTAIN THAT. AS CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO MOVE WELL THE FIRST
SEMESTER HOLDEN. SECOND MR TANG.
WHAT TRY ONE MORE TIME MAYBE WE
COULD TRY CONNECTING MISS
JESSICA BARTHOLOMEW AND MISTER
CARLOS BUCKET ON ALL. WE'RE TRY
AGAIN WITH THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF WE OF JESSICA
BARTHOLOMEW AND CARLOS BUT GET
ON ON THE LINE. AT THIS TIME I
DON'T THE OTHER EITHER ONE OF
THEM ON THE LINE. UP THEY ARE
ON THE LINE THEY CAN RAISE
THEIR HAND BY PRESSING ONE THAN
ZERO. AND AS LONG AS WE'RE
DOING THAT MAYBE WE CAN START
LINING UP THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL. MAIN OPPOSITION WHICH WAS
A NOT SO HERNANDEZ. AND POMELO
LOOMIS. WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT
JUST TO GET THAT STARTED NOW.
AND AJUSCO BARTHOLOMEW IS ON
THE LINE- JUST GOT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I MAY OCCUR PAID YES
PLEASE. GREAT THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS JEFF
BORZELLO WITH THE WEAPONS AND
I'M ON POVERTY CALLING IN
PLEDGING SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
AND YOU KNOW THE COVERAGE
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY HAVE LEFT MANY
CALIFORNIANS NOT ONLY OUT OF
WORK BUT REQUIRED A HOME AND TO
DO THEIR WORKING AND LEARNING
AND FUNCTIONING WHILE THEY'RE
STAYING HOME WITH ME FOR
CONNECTIVE ITTY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAS NEVER BEEN GREATER.
INTERNET HEALTH THAT ARE
EXTREMELY BIRD AND LIVE AT THIS
TIME FOR THAT BECAUSE THE FANG
HONG NOT THAT THE CONNECTIVE
SCHOOL EMPLOYMENT AND- IN THE
OPENING HALF THE MONEY BUT ALSO
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND-
AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
CONNECTING TO AT THEIR DOCTOR
AND TO HELP PROFESSIONALS WHEN
NECESSARY. THESE WITH THESE
ONLINE- ACCESS TO TELEPHONE AND
INTERNET IS ALSO BECOMING
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT IN ORDER
TO SECURE FOOD. IT WAS REPORTED
LAST MONTH THAT DURING THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE CODE. AT
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ONE IN
FIVE. AMERICAN ADULTS
EXPERIENCE HUNGER. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE CALIBRATION
PROGRAM INCREASED ITS
APPLICATIONS LIKE OVER 2100% IN
THAT FIRST TWO WEEK PERIOD OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. WE
WILL NOW THAT ACCESS TO PHONE
AND INTERNET IS ESSENTIAL
DURING THE CALL. BUT NOT ONLY
THAT BEYOND THE COMBAT GREAT
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM IS THE ONLY
PROGRAM THAT EXISTS TO PROTECT
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WITH TOO MANY
CASES SERVICES AND TO DO SO IN
A WAY THAT THEY AND THAT THE
PORTABLE AND DOESN'T FORCE THEM
TO MAKE THAT DECISION BETWEEN
FOOD. AND HOUSE. EDUCATION THIS
PROGRAM CHRIS QUICKLY RAMPED UP
WHEN AT THE SERVICES ARE NEEDED
ANSWERS TO PUT TOGETHER
ADDITIONAL SERVICES WINDOWS ARE
APPROPRIATE TO HELP AT THE
HOUSEHOLD TO BENEFIT FROM THE
PROGRAM AND TO ACT IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE PURPOSE OF
THE PROGRAM. WITHOUT ACCESS TO.
EDUCATION EITHER BY PHONE FAX
OR INTERNET LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WILL NOT ONLY
STRUGGLED THROUGHOUT THE COLOR
CRISIS WHICH WE EXPECT WILL
HAVE IMPACT ON OUR NEED TO-
MODERATE PEOPLE AT ACTIVITIES
INCOME FOR MONTHS IF NOT YEARS
AHEAD. BUT ALSO BEYOND THAT.
AND WE THINK TO GET OUT OF. ONE
OF THE WORST RECESSION OF OUR
LIFETIME IS NOT THE WORST AS WE
SEE TAKE TO HAVE- CALIFORNIANS
GET BACK TO WORK. GETTING THAT
PHONE CALL FROM IN HERE AT IS
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
IN ORDER TO THAT AND WE
INCLUDED. THIS BILL AND BODIES
OUR VISION OF WHAT WE CAN DO AT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TOGETHER CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM
WORKS FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE. AT
THAT IT WORKS FOR THE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
HAVE A WITH THE SERVICE
PROVIDER AND THAT IT DOES SO IN
A WAY THAT THE TARGET THE MOST.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE. LEAVING
GIVEN ALL FACILITY IS PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE IDEAS AND HOW
THEY ARE A CHALLENGE TO GET
THEM AS THE DMB IS CLOSER HAVE
LIMITED SERVICE. I KNOW I
PERSONALLY HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM- WHEN I
HAD AN UNCLE WHO IS HOME LIFE
AND IN ORDER TO HELP HIM.
BECOME CLEAN AND GET HEALTHY
AND BE CONNECTED TO THE FAMILY.
AS DURING A REALLY HARD TIME IN
HIS LIFE THE LIFELINE PROGRAM
HELPED US TO DO THAT. ONLY
BELIEVE IN THIS PROGRAM. A
MODEL OF- OF WHAT GOOD
GOVERNMENT LOOK LIKE AND WHAT
WE CAN DO. IT PARTICIPATION
RATE IS THE LOWEST OF ANY
PUBLIC PROGRAMS SERVING ONLY
COMES CALIFORNIANS. AND WE CAN
DO THAT. I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN
US IN SUPPORTING THE BILL-
ATTITUDE THAT WELL. IN THE
BATTLE CLOSE OUR STATE FOR
QUESTIONS IF NECESSARY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THEN WE HAVE
MISSED ARNOLD BUCKET. GONNA
SORRY. IF YOU CAN HAVE HIM
PLUGGED IN THE LINE NOW. AND
CARLOS SO IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MR
SHOULD JUST BECAUSE WE CAN'T
FIND IN WOULD YOU BE OKAY WE'VE
CONTINUED OPPOSITION OF THE
FINAL COME BACK ON. THANK YOU.
THE OPPOSITION OF WE HAVE
MISTER EGGNOG SHOW HERNANDEZ-
JOIN US NOW. OR PAMELA LOOMIS
WHOEVER IS AVAILABLE. HI THIS
IS A DOCTOR CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. AFTER HAND WITH. THE
HELP OF THE TOOLS WE REFORM
THAT LOCAL FIRMS TURN. AS
CONSUMER PROTECTION
ORGANIZATION A PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON ADVOCATING FOR. LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. TURNED OUT SUPPORT
YOUR OVERALL WALDRON CRISTINA
FORMAT AND PARTICIPATION.
PROGRAM IN FACT TURN HAS WORKED
HEAVILY FOCUSED COMMUNITY LEVEL
AT. THE LEGISLATURE. THE END OF
FEDERAL LEVEL WHEN SHE THIS
PROBE IS AVAILABLE THIS POP.
FORTUNATELY THE BILL CURRENTLY
DROUGHT AND A LIGHT OF CURRENT
PROCEEDINGS THAT THE CPC TURN
IN THE POST TO- TO THE BILL. I
WE HAVE YEP. TO THE AUTHOR AND
SHARE HIS OVERALL GOAL I WE
HAVE WORK CALLED YASIR OVER THE
YEARS AND EXPECTED CAN YOU
DEMONSTRATE NOT WHO STARTED TO
RUB YOU BUT IF YOU COULD SPEAK
A LITTLE LOUDER AND CLEARER WE
MEMBERS. HERE YOU. LOW IS THAT
YOU CAN ALWAYS TURN IT DOWN BI
POLAR. INTERRUPTING OKAY. NO NO
PROBLEM- THE METER TO THE FIRST
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS BALLS
PROBLEMATIC FOR US AND THAT IS
PREVENTION RELATED TO BE A PART
FOR YOU- WE DO NOT SUPPORT. HE
PROPOSED SIX MONTHS OR THIRTY
THREE- DO NOT BELIEVE IT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS TO BE LOCKED CARRIER
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME. AND
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES THE ADOPTED. A SHORTER.
AT LEAST FOR THAT ACT THE LAND
ON THE FOUR HOUR PERIOD FINDING
LONGER PERIOD WITHIN THEIR
COUPLE. PASSED IN. ABOUT COME
CUSTOMER WE SEE NO REASON RIGHT
NOW TO GO BEYOND THE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PERIOD OF. IT TO MAKE
IT A MY PORTABILITY STREETS AND-
THEN BROUGHT THIS UP BEFORE
THIS IS AN ONGOING DISCUSSION.
SO UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. BALANCE OF THE BILL I
TURN UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TIMES
THAT MAY BE NECESSARY. TO
ACCELERATE THE TIMELINE TO THE
CPSC. HOWEVER WE ARE PLEASED
THAT THE COMMISSION IT RECENTLY
INTIATE A PROCEEDING TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS YOUR
MOMENT ISSUE I ONE. TURN AND
OTHERS PARTICIPATING IN THAT
PROCESS AND IT'S BEEN VERY
PRODUCTIVE. AND WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE WILL HAVE SOME VERY
GOOD OUT. OF ACTUALLY THIS
WOULD DICTATE SOME OF THE
OUTCOME AND THAT'S CONCERNING
DO NOT WANT TO LOSE THAT BUT-
FOR THE COMMISSION STAKEHOLDER
TO DEVELOP. PRACTICAL AS
POSSIBLE. PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND THIS GOES IT WILL
TRY TO HAND OF THE OF THE
COMMISSION. AND OF ALL OF
WORKING ON IT THE MOST HELPFUL
SOLUTION POSSIBLE SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU AND IF WE
HAVE MISS PAMELA LOOMIS IS
PAMELA LOOM AS I APOLOGIZE FOR
COULD BE PLUGGED INTO THE CALL
PLEASE. YES FAMILIES ON HER
LINES OPEN AND PLEASE SPEAK
LOUD AND CLEAR. RIGHT I GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHAL
OF MY CLIENT CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS AND CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES. FIRST WE WOULD LIKE
TO COMMEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S COMMITMENT TO THE LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM IT IS AN
IMPORTANT SAFETY NET THAT WE
FULLY EMBRACED AND SUPPORT.
HOWEVER WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE
RESURRECTION OF THE PORTABILITY
THREES OF ANY BLANKS BEYOND THE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS ESTABLISHED
BY THE PC. NOT LONG AFTER
ADOPTING A PORTABILITY FREE THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION ELIMINATED IT
BECAUSE THE FCC FOUND THAT THAT
THE PORTABILITY FREEZE
DISADVANTAGE CONSUMERS. BY
RESTRICTING THEIR ABILITY TO
EITHER CHANGE CARRIERS OR TO
GET THEIR LIFELINE BENEFITS.
THEY'RE FIVE THEREBY MAKING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF
TRACKING THE PORTABILITY FREEZE
UNSUPPORTABLE. THE P. YOU SEE
AGREED WITH THE FCC AND
FOLLOWED SUIT. WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT AB THIRTY
SEVENTY NINE WOULD MISALIGNED
THE CALIFORNIA LIFELINE PROGRAM
WITH THE FEDERAL PROGRAM. BY
ALLOWING FORMS OF
IDENTIFICATION AND PROGRAM
BASED QUALIFICATION NOT
RECOGNIZED BY THE FCC. WE
CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH BUT
HARMONIZING THE STATE LIFELINE
PROGRAM WITH THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM REDUCES CONFUSION FOR
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS. AND EVEN
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
CALIFORNIA'S LIFELINE
ADMINISTRATOR AND CARRIERS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE NO UNLESS EIGHTY THIRTY
SEVENTY NINE IT'S AMENDED TO
ALIGN WITH THE FEDERAL LIFELINE
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
UNLESS MR OF BUCKET ON WAS ON
THE PHONE AND CAN GET PLUGGED
IN I ASKED THE CHAIR IF I COULD
JUST CONTINUE I'M SORRY THAT'S
THE- AUTHOR OF I CAN JUST
CONTINUE. IT KIND OF LOOK
AROUND- BUT AFTERNOON THANK YOU
AB GIVE CLEARLY INTO THE
MICROPHONE AND LOUD. MY NAME IS
CARLOS LOOKING ON ALL I
UNDERTAKE YOUR DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL MISSING ACOSTA A MEDAL
OF CRITICAL TO TRY- NEWSSTAND
THIRTEEN. BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
LAKE DON DOLLAR SIGN DELAYS ON
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
SALVADORAN AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND. SO MAKE
THE CHAIR. OF YOU KNOW ALL THE
GOVERNMENTAL SERVICE A LOT OF
INCOME FAMILIES- UNDERSERVED
HUNDRED YOU WILL FIND IT. CALL
THE NINETEENTH UP OF COURSE
CHANGE THAT. SO I THINK YOU FOR
GOVERNMENT TO REALLY SET THE
SACRAMENTO- TO HELP PROVIDE
RELIEF AND RECOVERY. I CALLED
TODAY TO RESPECT REQUIRES YOU
TO VOTE FOUR EIGHT THREE THREE
SEVEN NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
LOT OF THE WORK VIA. A BILL
THAT TRIED TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY OF THE MUCH NEEDED
CALIFORNIA LAST. LIFELINE
PROGRAM. IF WE PUT. NOT ALLOWED
LIKE BOEING HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT TO MANY OF OUR OUT OF
WORK OUT OF EIGHT ANON CONNECT
THE COGNITIVE THEM OUT. I HAVE
WORKED INCREASED PARTICIPATION
THIS PHONE IN THE POT. I HAVE
SEEN MANY TEACHERS FOR EXAMPLE
PROBABLY. BUT TO RE ENROLL IT
WAS LONG AND THEY GET IT BAKER
BROKE ON IT THE- ARE THEY HAVE
TO GIVE THEM THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. THE CITY IS FILLED
UP THERE ON THE STAND THE LEGAL
COMMUNITY. WHEN I WAS THE SOLID
STRENGTHENING GREASE AND
ROAMING ABOUT FLYING IF YOU
USE. IF YOU SEE DOLLARS TO BE A
PART OF THE PROCEEDING. AND I
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THE KIND OF
MONEY AND TIME FOR THE- RIGHT
NOW UP TO THE GOVERNMENT WAS
TRYING TO ROLE OF MANY LOW
EQUAL PROMISE OF POSSIBLE. SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO STAY IN
TOUCH WITH THEM WHAT THEY ARE
UP ON. WE HOPE THAT THE BILL
WOULD HELP BUT THE GRIEF OF
WHICH- VIEWS LOW INCOME
FAMILIES NEED TO CONFIRM- THAT
THEY ARE YOU. I'M GOOD BENEFITS
SUCH A THING HAND BROKE BROKE
DOWN. I HAVE YOU. FOR A NIGHT
WHAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE ASK THEM TO GET PLUGGED IN
NOW NOT TO BE NAMED
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WILL GET PLUGGED IN
NOW AND I WOULD BE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
MINE WHO HAD A FIRST AND A
SECOND AND IT DOES ENJOY THE I
RECORD THE CHAIR. ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. IT'S KIND OF
WEIRD ASK QUESTIONS AS WELL.
FIVE MR GARCIA THANK YOU FOR
BRING THE BILL FORWARD I HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROVISION OF THE BILL RELATED
TO- EXTENDING LIFE BROADBAND
SUBSCRIPTION SO YOUR GOOGLE.
ASKS THE PUBLIC UTILITY COULD
IN ISSUE FOR. THE NEXT- I
BELIEVE IT'S- COUPLE OF YEARS
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT A LIFELINE
SUBSCRIBER. PERMITTED AN
ADDITIONAL SUBSCRIPTION FOR
BROADBAND SERVICE AND I'M
WONDERING WHY THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE DECISION TO
ESSENTIALLY POINTED TO THE
PIECE THE WHITE THIS IS THE
JUST. THE MADE BY. HI YEAH. THE
P. YOU SEE DECIDE. SUBSCRIPTION
BROADBAND WHAT WITH THE COST OF
BE A ON HOW TO BE. TO THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION WE ARE I
BELIEVE THAT THE CPC HAS A
COUPLE OF PROCEEDINGS UNDER
WAY. WHICH WOULD DETERMINE. THE
FEASIBILITY OF THE BROADBAND A
COMPONENT TO IT. WE KNOW THAT
IF THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE. THAT
ARE USING THE LIVE SERVICE. AT
THAT WOULD. ALSO BE A IN THE
CREASE IN THE SURCHARGE- TOOLS-
HELPFUL. LINE WITH THAT BEING
SAID- THAT'S THE DECISION THAT
WAS MADE BECAUSE OF THE
PROCEEDINGS ARE HAPPENING AT
THE SCENE YOU SEE. SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THIS WOULD- THE
EXTENSION OF LIFE LINE TO
BROADBAND WOULD BE FUNDED BY
THE EXISTING SURCHARGE. ON WERE
PROVINCIAL PHONE SERVICE COULD
POTENTIALLY WHAT'S ONE REMIND
PEOPLE WERE STILL BE TALKING TO
CHAIR. INSURE THAT WE CONDUCT
BUSINESS NORMALLY. FEDERAL OKAY
I KIND OF HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT BECAUSE- IN MY OPINION IF
YOU'RE GOING TO CREATE A
BROADBAND AND LIFELINE PROGRAM
YOU SHOULD THROUGH SURCHARGE ON
INTERNET SERVICE NOT SURCHARGES
ON RESIDENT PHONE SERVICE- ERR
ESSENTIALLY WE'VE GOT A SHOT
CONSUMER THAT EVEN BY READ.
SERVE AND I'M NOT SURE WOULD BE
THROUGH SURCHARGES PHONE
SERVICE WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN AT SERVICE HI BUT IN A
IN A BROADER SENSE I THINK
THESE ARE DECISIONS THAT WE
SHOULD BE MAKING HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND I OBJECT TO
ESSENTIALLY PUNTING BUT
DECISION PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IF IT IS A
WORTHWHILE THING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT INDEED IT'S- WE HAVE HAD
A KERR. ABOUT YOUR- THIS IS.
THANK ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MR
KAMLAGER DOES. AND I ASKED THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR JUST TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ANYBODY
STILL NOT ON THE FOR OR AGAINST.
LINE OF PEOPLE IF THERE IS ANY
GO AHEAD MR ON LATE NIGHT
GERMAN- IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
YOU OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE- AT
THIS TIME YOU'LL HEAR TOWN IN
PLACE YOU AN OPERATOR THAN
GOING TOGETHER NAME. WHAT DO.
CAN YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
CAN WE DO IT I'M DOING UP JUST
TAKE A MOMENT IN THE MEANTIME
GONNA HAVE THIS ORDER. THANK
YOU. THIS IS INCOME A POLICE
ARE REAL. I'M SIR GARCIA I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD. SHARE
WITH US THE REASONING BEHIND
THE SIX MONTH AFFORDABILITY
FREEZE IT- THERE'S AN FOR MY
READING OF THE BILL GOES FROM
SIXTY DATED SIX MONTH AND- THIS
IS COMMON WHAT WILL. PROCESS
THREE DATA BEHIND THAT DECISION.
THANK YOU SO WE ARE ON
CONVERSATIONS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF TIME THE PURPOSE OF PUT
FREEZE IS TO TRY TO GET KIND OF
A HANDLE ON THE PORTABILITY OF
SERVICES THAT. PLACER COMPANIES
OUT ANDERSON. BECAUSE PROMOTING
CERTAIN TYPES OF WELL-
TECHNOLOGIES OR FOR THAT MATTER
SERVICES AND PEOPLE IN THE
INTERESTS OF JUST- OUR COMPANY
IS IN THE INTERESTS AND GET THE
CUSTOMERS TO LINE UP THERE JUMP.
PROVIDERS CONSISTENT BASE WITH
A WE'RE TRYING TO BRING. SOME
STABILITY TO THE PROGRAM TO GET
A- GOOD SENSE OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN ROLLING. A AND
THEREFORE CONTINUE TO PROMOTE-
THE EXPANSION ARE TOO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TO ENROLL INTO
THESE PROGRAMS THE NUMBER COULD
CHANGE THAT HAVE TO BE SIX
MONTHS WERE OPEN TO.
DESCRIPTIONS OF THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND I'VE BEEN ADVISED
TO ASK THE EIGHTY IN MY AGE TO
MODERATE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
STILL ON THE LINE. IT IS. YEAH
THREE- SO FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP REBEKAH GONZALEZ AND
ITS NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE BUT NEXT
WEEK GO TO THE LINE OF JUST
SELL A MILLION. YEAH DO YOU
THINK IT'S A LOT MORE YOUNGER
BUT THE CLEAN ANY IS TO. THE
GREEN LINE IS. TO AND WE GO TO
LINE OF NATHAN JOHNSON PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JOHN FIOS TRUE
CONNECT IN SUPPORT. AND THE
FACT MAY FIFTY THINGS. ALL NAME
AND AN TO SIN ONLY RIDE TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE. JOB THIRTY
OVERTURE CONNECT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE A ONE
MORE IT'LL JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO GET THEIR NAME. FROM. IN THE
MEANTIME I'VE ALSO AT THE
REQUEST OF THERE'S ANYBODY IN
PUBLIC. OKAY I SEEN ON FOSTER
THAT. THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
BEARING WITH THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME DOING THIS AND I'VE BEEN
JOB BROWN JUST MOVING QUICKER
POSTED SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
IS THAT PERSON AVAILABLE. LOOKS
LIKE FIVE AT THIS TIME THE
ALTHOUGH WE HAD IN Q. THEY'RE
ABLE TO SPEAKING ON NAME
POSITION ONLY. ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ONLY. OTHER LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
ONLY. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON-
BRENDA PALOMINO HERE WITH-
BRENT IT NOW PART OF T. MOBILE
AND MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE OURSELVES IN- THE
POSITION WITHOUT ACTUALLY A
FORMAL POSITION WOULD LIKE OUR
CONCERNS WITH THAT WORK
CHELATED BY. AT A PREVIOUS.
YEAH ONLY BECAUSE WE'RE SAYING
IT ORG POSITION. ATANY CLOSING
ON THE COMMENTS MISTER A RUSSIA
IS A CHAIR IN COLLEAGUES WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT THERE IS
PUBLIC HEALTH THIS IS THE
INCREASE OF PARTICIPATE AND FOR
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN AND IT'S-
NOT REMAIN. THE PERCENT YOU
POSITION WE WANT MAKE SURE THAT
WE EXPAND. THE PROGRAM TO AS
MANY LOW INCOME FAMILIES AS
POSSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA. I
WANTED JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT- THERE ARE- COUPLE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
OCCUR WITH THE OPPOSITE. AND
PARTICULARLY REGARDING THE
APPROPRIATE. AND FINDING A THE
AMOUNT OF DAYS THAT MAKES MORE
SENSE AT THE- NUMBER THAT SPENT
ON AUTHORS. USER SO HAVE. I
THOUGHT IT WAS A REASONABLE
AMOUNT THE SAME TIME THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE FCC AND
JEOPARDIZING ANY POTENTIAL
FUNDING CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH ANY
OF THE- THAT THE FCC. WE
PROGRAM WE DO WANT TO MAKE A
POINT THAT WE CAN STRETCH OUR
SELVES- WITHIN- THE ABILITY
THAT WE HAVE IS A STATE TO BE
ABLE TO READ MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILY THAT MAY MEAN THAT WE
MEAN NINE. THE WITH THE FCC. OR
THE FEATHER. THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST TIME. AND THE- LAST. BUT
WE DON'T WANT TO JEOPARDIZE ANY
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES THAT
COULD BENEFIT THE STATE SO
WE'RE- MISSING THAT. AND ARE
WILLING TO ALSO PROVISION IN
THE BILL. THAT WOULD STIPULATE
THAT MOVING FORWARD SO JUST
WANTED TO. ADDRESS THOSE.
CONSERVE MISTER. NOTE ON SOME
QUESTIONS WHEN WE WILL KEEP
THOSE ARE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
RESPECT WE HAVE THREE. THANK
YOU HAD A FIRST THIS ENJOY THE-
AND TOWARDS THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR OF ROLL CALL
PLEASE. AB THREE ZERO SEVEN
NINE THE MOTION HAS BEEN PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO ON OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI BONTA BONTA
BROUGH. BRAIN NOT VOTING TING.
CHANGE FIVE THE WATER GARCIA.
THE WATER GARCIA HI HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I'D A LONGER. KAMLAGER
ONLINE LOW. LOW I HAD A- THE
CHILDREN. FOR CHILDREN NOT
VOTING RODRIGUEZ. EIGHT ZERO
CAPITAL ABOUT. BANKING
REGULATIONS TO. I WANT TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BILL ON THE
STREET CHAO YOU'RE HERE. AND I
WANT TO FIRST THANK YOU FOR
EXT- FOR YOU EXTREMELY HARD
WORK IN PUTTING ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS THE
COMING OUT WITH A PRODUCT THAT
I THAT I THINK OF THEM AS A
MATTER TO PASS AND- THANK YOU
ONCE. AND THE AUTHOR OMITTED
ALSO COMMANDMENTS WHICH WOULD
BE TAKE A LOOK AT THE BEING
COMMITTEE YOU SHOULD HAVE A
MOTTO FORM IN FRONT OF YOU CAN
BE FOR YOU- AND IT'S ALSO
STATED IN THE ANALYSIS WERE
SIXTY FIVE IS NOT READ THE BILL
BUT I'LL LET MR CHOW ON MUCH.
IT CHAIR AND NUMBER SIDE. ONE
TO START BY SAYING THAT SOME.
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED. ABOUT
THE ROBO CALL MITIGATION
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. PASSED
TO THE TECHNOLOGY. HE HE'S
ABILITY OF CERTAIN ASPECTS OF
THEIR INTENDED REACH. WELL I
THINK THAT THE ULTIMATE
OBJECTIVE SHOULD BE TO GIVE
CONSUMERS AS MUCH POSSIBLE.
CONTROL COSTS VOTE. OVER BUT
ROLL ALSO. OUR ABC I DO WANT
TO. ADDRESS MAJOR OPPOSITIONS
CONCERN. SO THEREFORE I AM
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENT
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE MOCK UP
THAT WAS PROVIDED WITH THE BILL
AND- THIS. BUDGET REMOVE. FIVE
THE BILL IN THE HIRING WHICH
INCLUDES ALL THE RELATED TO
CALL MITIGATION TECH. AB THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN WITH STRENGTH IN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
MANAGING AND WANT TO REBEL
CALLS BY GIVING CONSUMERS
GREATER CONTROL OVER CONSENTING
TO RECIEVE ROBO CALLS AND
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
AUTOMATIC DIALING AND
ANNOUNCING DEVICE TO COVER MORE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT MAKE
AUTOMATED CALLS SO CONSUMERS
CAN. CONSENT TO RECEIVE THOSE
TYPES OF CALLS REBEL CALLS ARE
A GROWING PROBLEM IN OUR
SOCIETY AS WE KNOW ACCORDING TO
TRANSACTION NETWORK SERVICES
THERE WERE ONE HUNDRED AND SIX
BILLION NUISANCE RUBBLE COSTS
AND- TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
CALIFORNIA RECEIVING AND
SENDING MORE CALLS TO IN. THE
STATE. CURRENTLY THE GROWING
FREQUENCY OF RUBBLE CALLS A
MAKING CONSUMERS HE DIDN'T
LEAVE RATED REBEL. TOP COMPLAIN
OF CONSUMERS TO THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION. MORE
AND MORE CONSUMERS ARE
REGISTERING FOR THE NATIONAL DO
NOT CALL LIST. A NUMBER OF
ACTIVELY REGISTER PHONE NUMBERS
ON THE LIST HAS BEEN YOU TO
ROLL FROM TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION EIGHT. THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FRUIT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
MILLION IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
FURTHERMORE BETWEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
COMPLAINTS TO THE F. T. C.
ABOUT VIOLATIONS OF THE DO NOT
CALL LIST ROSE FROM THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION COMPLAINTS. THE SPREAD
OF THE COOLEY NINETEEN POINT DE
MAKE ALL THERE WERE CONSERVING
REPORTS OF A GROWING NUMBER NAY
SCANNABLE CALLS AND TEXT. HI TO
THE PANDEMIC. SCAMMERS OPPOSING
AS GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS LIKE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
WELL US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES OFFICIALS.
GAP RANGE FROM FAKE TASK FOR A
HOME TO KIT FIG TREE OR CURES
FRAUDULENT STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT CLASS FRAUDULENT
FEDERAL STIMULUS CHECKS SCHEMES
SMALLVILLE. VIRUS RELATED LOAN
SCHEMES ONLINE LISTING
VERIFICATION SCHEMES AND
FRAUDULENT WORK FROM HOME
SCHEMES. THIS CLEARLY SHOWS HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF REBEL CALL. THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COAL QC SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
SEVEN TWO THREE PROHIBITS
CALLING A PERSON WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT WHEN USING AN AUTOMATED
DIALING ANNOUNCING DEVICE THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF THESE
DEVICES. TO YOU SEE 28-7 TEAM
HOWEVER LEAVES OUT TECHNOLOGY
THAT MAY INCORPORATE AUTO
DIALERS TO CONNECT LIVE HUMANS
WITH THE PERSON CALLED LEAVING
OUT A CONSENT REQUIREMENT FOR A
LARGE PORTION OF REBEL CALLS.
AB THREE THOUSAND AND EXPANDS
THE DEFINITION OF AUTOMATED
DIALING AND NOW SING DEVICE TO
COVER THE USE OF MENDES. WHAT'S
A LIST TELEPHONE NUMBER
AUTOMATIC MOST OR AUTOMATICALLY
SO TEX MEX. TO NUMBERS ON THE
LIST WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT HUMAN
INVOLVEMENT IN THE ACT OF
CALLING WAS SENDING. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES THE SERVERS TO
REVOKE THEIR CONSENT TO RECEIVE
A REBEL CALL AT ANY TIME AND
ANY REASONABLE MANNER I HAVE TO
BE NECESSARY TODAY I'M MORE WE
ONLY BE HOW THE SPONSOR
CONSUMER REPORTS. AS WELL AS
THE NOT A CAR WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. IS A
ALSO RESPECT YOUR FOR YOUR. WE
HAVE MISSED CAN THE MOVE THE
BILL FIRST. HELLO MISTER HALL
SECOND POSSIBLE REMIND YOU IF
YOU'RE THE PUBLIC AND WANT TO
CALL NOW STRUGGLING NOW TO BE
GET PUT IN THE QUEUE AT THE AT
AND T. MODERATOR TO PUT PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE- BY THE TIME THE
MAIN SUPPORT NOT. IN THE SPOKE
AT THE A- THE MOVE IN. I WOULD
LIKE TO. CALL THE FIRST A MEANS
FOR WITNESSES TO PROCEED MARINE
THE CONFERENCE I BELIEVE.
IN
MARIN IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU FOR PATIENTS MEMBERS THIS
WAS TESTED EARLIER SO WE KNOW
SHE'S THERE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COULD NOT BE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR. YES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CHAIR SANTIAGO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M A
POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS AND WE'RE PROBABLY
SPONSORING A BILL TO GIVE
CONSUMERS CONTROL OF THE
BOMBARDMENT OF REBEL CALLS
WHICH ARE I WANTED OTHER DIALED
CALLS IN TAX. AS FOR CALLING
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE
LANDMARK TELLS. THE CPA ONE
SETS COMPUTERIZED CALLS OR THE
SCORES OF MODERN CIVILIZATION
THEY WAKE US UP IN THE MORNING
THE INTERRUPTER DINNER AT NIGHT
THEY FORCE THE SICK AND ELDERLY
OUT OF BED AND THEY HELPED US
INTO A READY TO RIP THE
TELEPHONE RIGHT OUT OF. WALL
WE- REBEL CALLS ARE A MAJOR
DISTURB. TO CONSUMERS PEACE AND
PRIVACY BECAUSE THEY TELL US IS
ONE OF THE TOP COMPLAINTS. FROM
CONSUMERS AND THEY TELL US THAT
REBEL CALLS HAVE INTERFERED
WITH THAT WHEN THEY'RE TRYING
TO DIAL OUT IN AN EMERGENCY-
THAT THEY INTERRUPT WHEN
THEY'RE TALKING ON THE PHONE TO
THEIR DOCTOR. AND NOT WORKERS
IN. THAT WAS IN A THEIR SLEEP
ARE WHEN THEY'RE TRYING SLEEP
DURING THE DAY. THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY IN IN LIGHT OF THE
COPA NINETEEN CRISIS OR HEARING
DISTURBING REPORTS OF-
INCREASES IN TELEMARKETING ROBO
CALLS PARTICULARLY SCANNABLE
CALLS TARGETING FOR EXAMPLE
FAKE OXANA VIRUS TESTING KIDS.
AND WITH THIEVES GOT
UNEMPLOYMENT IT'S LIKELY THAT
MANY CONSUMERS WILL FIND IT
DIFFICULT TO MAKE REGULAR
PAYMENTS ON LOANS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS AGAINST HARASSING
DEBT COLLECTION FOR. EXISTING
LAWS ALREADY PROVIDES A CONSENT
REQUIREMENT FOR MANY OTHER DIET
CALLS- WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS JUST TO CLOSE UP ANY
GAPS IN COVERAGE I TO MAKE SURE
THAT TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS
PREDICTIVE DIALERS. ART
INTELLIGENCE A TECHNOLOGY AND
ITS SO CALLED OF RECKLESS VOICE
MAIL ARE COVERED BY THE CONSENT
REQUIREMENT. WHEN INSURANCE
PAYMENT STRUCTURE OR HOME PHONE.
AS ARE I WOULD JUST HEALTH.
COMPLAINTS TUMORS. EXCEPT THESE
COST SO WE THINK THIS IS IN
CONCERN FOR LEGISLATION AND WE
ARE. THANK YOU. WE ALSO HAVE AN
EXTRA CAR FROM THE CONSUMER
TURNS CALIFORNIA VIA TELEPHONE.
AT THE EIGHTEEN TO MODERATE A
PLUG THAT IT. HI YES YOU KNOW
YOUR LINES OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER TO GET BACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
DURING THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY ABOUT AND-
IDEA THEIR IVORY AND THERE WERE
NOT MENTIONED CONSUMER. SO
CALLED BECAUSE THEY'RE GORGEOUS.
THE BAND OR TO OUT HIGH NUMBER
CALLS A VERY AMOUNT TIME
WRITTEN DEPENDS UPON THE PEOPLE
AT THE CARE ABOUT AND TOO OFTEN
THE MURDER REBEL CALL ABOUT
THAT EVEN FOR THAT ARE NOT FOR
THE FACT. THE WALL THERE MAY.
WHAT THE HARSH TWELVE BUT AT
THE AT THE OF MORE CALLER
ALTHOUGH AND FOR BEEN FOR
BETTER WILL BE IN AND OUT THAT
FOR TO GETTING THE WORD THE
ABILITY PAY NOW TO CALL WE URGE
YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU.
ASSOCIATION IN AND- SONYA
GIPSON FROM ENCORE CAPITAL. I
FORGET BEGIN IN THAT PARTICULAR
ORDER. THANK YOU WISCONSIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
C. K. ALSO THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHECK OUT TJ HAS
THROWN EVERYTHING IT CAN COME
AT THE- BIRBAL CALLED TO- HAD
MULTIPLE BACK TO SLEEP
DISSOLUTION TO A GROUP OF
COURSE ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENT
THE STATE ATTORNEY. INCLUDING
ATTORNEY GENERAL. OKAY PROVIDE
AMONG OTHER PRETTY BLAH IN
LABELING STICK AND- WE THE WORK
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO IT
CHAIR. IN BOTH THEIR STAFF OVER
THE WEEKEND TO WORK OUT AN
AGREEMENT ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AT THE CHAIR INDICATE
CLEAR ON WHAT THE ACCEPTANCE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT FIFTY AB
I WILL REMEMBER THE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL REALLY. THANK YOU
AND MISS MCINTYRE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAROLINE
MCINTYRE BE HAPPEN THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
I LIVE AT THE TI EIGHT OUR
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN WORKING
PURSUANT TO STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW. IT TECHNOLOGY TO COMBAT A
GLOBAL CALLED THE AND- FREE-
THAT WE'D LIKE TO TAKE A FAMILY
MEMBER CHAO TODAY HELLO WORK
FOR RECOGNIZING BAD. AND FOR
MAKING THE AMENDMENT THAT WAS
DESCRIBED EARLIER ADD TO AB
THREE. SEVEN TWO WEEKS WE WERE
OPPOSE WITH ADAM AND MATT AT
THE PTA WELL OP TO WITHDRAW
COMPETITION AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
SEMI MEMBER ON A COUPLE OF. ANY
ISSUES. YEAH I THANK YOU. NOW.
I WANNA ASK I KNOW JUMP AROUND
JUST TO MAKE IT RUN A LITTLE
BIT QUICKER I'VE BEEN FORMED IN
THE SUN YOU GIPSON IS PROBABLY
ON A DIFFERENT LINE SO WE'LL
GET TO ORAL IN A SECOND BUT IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL- SUPPORT
WITNESSES. THE BEEN CUED UP.
NASA MODERATOR PLACEMENT NOW.
YES TO KNOW AS A REMINDER IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO YOU'LL HEAR A TONE
INDICATING HERE IN THE QUEUE
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY PLEASE. WE HAVE OUR
SEVERAL QUEUING UP IT'LL JUST
BE A MOMENT SIR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY
PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
RIGHT IN THE- FIRST PERSON THAT
WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GO
TO A LINE OF EGG NO CO
HERNANDEZ- PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET
IT. DID NOT KILL HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF. COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF TURN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM I COULDN'T QUITE
HEAR WITH THE MEMONS WAR BUT
LOOK FOR TO- REVIEWING THOSE
MET. THANK YOU NEXT. AND THEN
THE NEXT ONE WE HAVING Q. WE GO
TO LINE OF- SHOULD MUHAMMAD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
WHAT MOM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB DURING
YOUR. SO JUST CONTINUE WITH THE
OPPOSITION HAS ANY OPPOSITION.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF HIS
GIPSON. AND AGAIN THAT WANT TO
GET TO JOIN THE QUEUE PLUS ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE SEVERAL IN
THE QUEUE JUST BE A MOMENT TO
GET THEIR NAME.
IN THE MEANTIME
THE MEMBERS OF THE FIRST
AVAILABLE TO WILL- IS JOHN
ERINDALE PLEASE GO AHEAD
JONATHAN HERE BONE BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF NATIONAL
ADVERTISERS ALSO OPPOSITION.
YOU. AND IF OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
QUEUE. I YES WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE IN THE QUEUE WE GO LIVE
COURTNEY JENSEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHARICE
ACCORDING KANSEN MY PACK MATT
RESPECTFULLY. IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE CAN CONTINUE WITH THE Q. WE
HAVE TWO MORE US WHEN YOU GET
THEIR NAME WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT.
THE NEXT WE'LL ITEM
MELANIE EQUATES TO GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS NINETY
THREE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THAT
MEASURE BUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE PROPOSAL MAY IMPACT
OUR EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THEM AND WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORIZATION
CURRENTLY. THE CONSISTENT.
THANK YOU. AND THE LAST ONE WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE AT THE
MOMENT- WILL GO LINE OF CLIFF
BURKE THE GUY HAD. UT BURKE.
NOT CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN. CLICK BURKE CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES HELLO YES WE CAN
I'M I THANK YOU CLIFFORD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS WE ARE OPPOSED I
KNOW IT'S A NAME IT AND-
POSITION ONLY BUT A ONE REQUEST
FOR ONE MINUTE INDULGENCE SO
THIRTY SECONDS- SINCE TO OUR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FLIPS ONLY
MODE BUT LET'S LET'S DO THIRTY
SECONDS IF THE COMMITTEE. IS
OKAY WITH A- THANK. THANK YOU
ARE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL WE DO BELIEVE IT IS OVER
BROAD THAT IT CONTEMPLATES ROBO
CALLS WITH THE TECHNOLOGY USED
TO PLACE. ALL OF THE BILL. THE
THING BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
EXEMPTION AN EXISTING LAW.
WHICH MEANS THAT BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTACT THEIR OWN CUSTOMERS OR
MANAGE THEIR ACCOUNTS BUT
WITHOUT GETTING THE EXPRESS
CONSENT. POST TRANSACTION. OF
THE CONSUMER OR DEBTOR- WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS VERY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN THAT THE
BILL IS. OVER BROUGHT IN WITH
SERIOUSLY IMPEDED COMMUNITIES
ABILITY. CONTACT WITH THEIR OWN
CUSTOMERS OWN ACCOUNTS. NO WHAT
WE ARE TO BE. WILL CALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE QUEUE ON HEARING
OUR STAFF THAT WE HAVE SOME LOS
ONE PERSON STILL OFTEN YOU. I
WANT TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO JOIN THE QUEUE. IN THE
MEANTIME- WE HAVE ONE MORE AND
YOU. ANYBODY PRESENT MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KRISTA KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF COUNTY THE
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS ASK IF YOUR
PATIENTS I'M HERE FOR OUR TEAM
TO STOP ONE PERSON STUCK IN THE
QUEUE. FIRST MISTER MODERATOR
YOU COULD MAYBE HELP US FIND
THAT PERSON. HI YES THE PERSON
THAT IN THE QUEUE IS MISSONI
GIPSON. THANK YOU IN AND I
THINK IT'S IN THE BEGINNING SHE
WAS WE ARE GOING TO GIVE A
FORMAL OPPOSITION FOR TWO
MINUTES. THE LONG KEY. IT AGAIN.
SON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS THIRTY GIPSON HERE IN
OPPOSITION FROM ON QUICK
CAPITAL GROUP. THIS BILL
DEFINITION CHANGE TO AUTOMATIC
DIALING DEVICE. IF DEEPLY
CONCERNING BECAUSE THE POLLS
AND THE TECHNOLOGY MOST
INDUSTRIES AND COMPANIES USE TO
CALL OR TEXT THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND RESPECT SUCH TECHNOLOGY.
REBEL CALLS ARE MADE WITH AUTO
DIALERS. THAT RANDOMLY GENERATE
PHONE NUMBERS AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL BEAMING ALL BATTLING
TECHNOLOGY WHICH BAKER CALLED
STORE TELEPHONE NUMBERS. AT THE
AUTO DIAL GLOBAL CALL.
COMPANIES USE TECHNOLOGY. TO
EFFECTIVELY OTHER CONSUMERS AND
THE PHONE NUMBERS OF THEIR CUT
ARE CONSUMER. WE HAVE FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS BILL WOULD
MEAN THAT WE HAVE TO MANUALLY
HAND OUT THEIR PHONE NUMBERS.
AND AT THIS BILL STEPPED.
KNOWLEDGE YOU BY THIRTY YEARS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY INCONCEIVABLE
TO THINK THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
MANUALLY HAND DIAL THE NUMBERS
ARE CONSUMERS. IN ORDER TO ASK
THE COMMISSION. HE THE DYING
TECHNOLOGY TO CALL THEM IN THE
FUTURE. RESPECTFULLY ASK THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WESTCHESTER MODERATED
BY BELIEVE ALL PEOPLE OFF THE
Q. PERFORMS TAKEN ANYBODY ADDED
ON LATE LET US KNOW OTHERWISE
WHEN A QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
THAT OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF MR CHOW YUN
I'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION
QUITE A FEW TIMES IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS- I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO- IN
REGARDS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
UNWANTED CALLS AND TEXTS TO.
PRESENT CORNER THANK YOU AND I
SHOULD GOAL I'M TRYING TO GET
TO A POSITION OF SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND IT'S CHANGED A LOT IN
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND
I AND YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I HAVE ONE MAJOR
CAN. IN WHICH IT. IN THIS BILL
THE MAN YOU ARE TAKING OUT
EXEMPTION FOR IS THAT THE PRE
TING RELATION WITH HER NUMBERS
TO BE ABLE TO TAX. CUSTOMER IN
AN ON CALL THE MINUTE MAID WHAT
AND IT HAD QUORUM THOSE COST.
TO HAVE A EXPRESS CAN OF THOSE
OF THE CUSTOMER BEFORE ISSUING
THAT. MANY SO MY- I CAN THIS IS
SO WE HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS
COME ACROSS THAT ALREADY HAVE A
WITH HER BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALREADY TECH THEM FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN I GO TO THE PHARMACY IF
I'M FEELING A PRESCRIPTION FOR
A FIFTH MEMBER I GET A BY TEXT
AND PERCEPTION HAS FILLED. I
WANT THAT TEXT BUT WOULD
EXPRESSLY CAN STAFF TO HAVE THE
EXTENT OF BUT UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THE PHARMACY DIDN'T
THIS BILL WAS COMING THERE
UNABLE TO HAVE ASKED ME FOR NOW
FOR THAT EXPRESSED CONCERN MY
QUESTION IS HOW YOU WANT TO DO
WITH THAT. BECAUSE PUTTING
THESE COMPANY A CATCH TWENTY
WORK YOU'RE REQUIRING ARKANSAS
THAT THEY DID KNOW THEY HAD
ASKED FOR. AND THEY DON'T HAVE
A WAY OF ASKING. CONSENT YOU'RE
NOT. THEM COMMUNITY CUSTOMERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION. I
THINK- DOT CONCERN IS ALSO WITH
ALSO ECHO BY A COUPLE OTHER ALL
COLORS. SO ARE THE YOU KNOW I
WANT TO. YOU KNOW MAKE THE
STATEMENT THAT UNDER OUR
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW THERE IS NO
EXISTING BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP-
IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA. HAVING
SAID THAT I THINK ARE
RIGHTFULLY SO THERE ARE
EXISTING CUSTOMERS WHO
PREVIOUSLY HAVE GIVEN THEIR
CONSENT. AND I THINK THE
LANGUAGE WOULD HAVE TO BE TWEAK
A LITTLE BIT MAKE OUT
ACCOMMODATION WE DON'T WANT ANY
REDUNDANCY IN THAT REGARD SO IF
CUSTOMER HAVE. ALREADY THEIR
CONCERN. WE NEED TO RETAIN THAT
IT WILL WANT THEM TO OUR KNOW
REEKER AGAIN SO THERE'S A THAT
WE NEED TO KIND OF YOU KNOW
GOING FORWARD OKAY WELL THE
QUOTA QUESTION SPECIFICALLY SO
I NEVER TOLD MY PHARMACY THAT
THEY HAD MY CONSENT TEXT THAT
MY PRESCRIPTION WAS VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT
THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH HAVE FOR
YOUR- HOW. HOW ARE THEY GOING.
MIKE INSTEAD IF THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO COME. BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME LIKE YOU NEED SOME KIND
OF A PROVISION. TO IF NOT
GRANDFATHER THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT ALLOW THEM A GRACE PERIOD
TO BE ABLE TO SAY HEY LOOK WE
NEED YOUR CONSENT TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE COMMUNICATING WITH YOU
YOU KNOW TAX BACK ONE IF YOU
CONSENT OR WHATEVER IT IS I
MEAN. IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A WAY TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM WITH WITHOUT. YOU KNOW
WITHOUT A STE- REQUIRING YOU
PUTTING ALL THESE COMPANIES IN
THIS CATCH TWENTY TWO YEAH I DO
SEE A CONCERN I THINK WHAT.
MISSION I THINK THE GRANDFATHER
PROVISION ME. AWAY RESULT THAT
IS. YOU KNOW WHAT. YEAH THE
ROCK IS AS WELL. AS WE GO FOR.
I AND IF YOU HAVE ANY SUCH. YOU
KNOW LET ME KNOW ALSO. AND SO
YOU KNOW IT IS SOMETHING THAT
TO LEGITIMATE CONCERN SO I WANT
TO RESOLVE DOWN ALSO. GOING
FORWARD BEFORE YOU KNOW GETS
TOO FAR OKAY SO JUST BE TO BE
CLEAR YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THAT WITH. WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS. THAT'S ALSO A
PROBLEM THAT'S THE GAME PLAN
YES OKAY. SHOT AND I HAD ONE
OTHER QUESTION WITH YOUR FOR
MISTER ISSUE. THERE YOU GO
AHEAD AND I'M WITH AND WE GOT A
COUPLE OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THERE
IS A SECTION OF THE BILL ON THE
VERY FIRST PART. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I FIND A LOT IT
SAYS. IT'S THE END OF THE-
PLACE. AUTOMATIC DIALING.
ANNOUNCING DEVICES. BE INTER.
AS TO PREVENT THE EXT. OF
AUTOMATICALLY. DESIGNED TO
EVADE THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
ARTICLE. THAT'S SOMETHING I
VERY RARELY SEEN IN
LEGISLATION. I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE INTENT IS. BUT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW ON EARTH YOU
WOULD EVER ENFORCE THAT
ARTICLE IS VERY SPECIFIC. AND
IF SOMEONE DESIGNS. AUTOMATED
DIALING EQUIPMENT TO EVADE THAT
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN. SAY
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
KNOW WE- WE THINK IS ON THE
RIGHT AUTOMATED DIALING
EQUIPMENT. FOR WE'RE NOT TO
TELL YOU EXACTLY. WHAT IT IS. I
GOT IT SO WE'LL BE HAPPY AT
THAT AS WELL. OKAY YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH THE INTEL LANGUAGE IS
NOT BINDING OBVIOUSLY AS YOU
KNOW SO. SO WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
CONNECT WITH GOD IF NECESSARY.
BUT JUST DOESN'T SEEM TO ME
THAT IT ACCOMPLISHES ANYTHING
IT JUST ADDS MORE CONFUSION
THAN IT DOES SOLVE PROBLEMS.
RIGHT THANK YOU ABSOLUTELY.
THANK MISTER VICE CHAIR AT. AND
MISTER LOAN- I APOLOGIZE FOR
OVERLOOKING THAT EARLIER THANK
YOU KNOW NO WORRIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND MISS THE CHAIR
AND- I COLLEAGUES- SUMMER
CALVET. ASSIMILATE JUST WANT TO
ECHO. I WAS PREVIOUSLY ADDRESS
WITH THAT OF A SIMILAR
OBERNOLTE. OF COURSE MY LOOK AT
THE WHEN I READ THIS BILL OF
COURSE- IT WOULD BE PIERRE THAT
EVERYONE HAS. THIS PROBLEM SO.
SHAPING THIS FOR BUT- THAT MUCH
MORE IN SUPPORT NOW- TO HEAR
THE KNOWLEDGE MANY OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT WE CAN
STILL ADDRESS. WITH HIS
EXPLICITLY WITHIN FARMS. WITHIN
THE BEAM HE THAT IS A- CONCERN
THAT I KNOW THAT WELL WE'VE
ALSO HEARD. AS WELL TOO SO.
WHAT WITH YOU COMMITTEE. WAS
OUTSTANDING ISSUES BUT A
NONETHELESS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE A BRING THIS FOURTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS A ESPECIALLY IF
IT CONCERNS PHARMACIES FOR
EXAMPLE I HAD A PRESCRIPTION
THAT WAS RENEWED WAS ON
AUTOMATIC RENEWAL I GOT A TEXT.
THAT SAID WOULD YOU LIKE TO
AUTOMATICALLY RENEW THIS ID
TECHS ABOUT YET. AND THEN I GOT
A RESPONSE BECAUSE THE CLOVER
NINETEEN SAYING INSTEAD OF
COMING TO THE STORE SHOULD WE
SEND IT TO YOU. LOST SO AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS. DEMOCRATS
QUESTION. THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING BE THERE'S TO HELP
PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO ARE STAYING
AT HOME AND YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
ARE WILL NEED THIS THING
STAYING AT HOME UNTIL THERE'S.
THAT WITH ALL THINK YOU'RE- I
AGREE TO CONTAIN WORKING WITH
TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE SERVING
EVERYBODY THINKS WHEN WILL TAKE
EFFECT. THANK YOU I NEED.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
BELIEVE WE HAD A FIRST AND
SECOND. ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
PUSH FOR. I'M SORRY ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS A MISTER TELL AND I
APOLOGIZE MEMBERS ABOUT. OUR
OUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE MUCH. THANK
YOU WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HARD WORK BRING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN REMOVING SO- A
GOOD PORTION OF THE OPPOSITION
SAW WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO- IT
ENJOYS THE- AND I FROM THE
CHAIR- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHT THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO HI OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE ARE BOERNER HORVATH
THE LETTER THAT BONTA. BONTA
BROUGH PLEASE NOTE CHAIN.
TWENTY FIVE THERE WERE GARCIA.
IN ORDER GARCIA HOLDEN. HOLDEN
ARAKAN LONGER. PHONE ORDER
ONLINE LOAN. LAURIE ARE
PATTERSON. THE CHILDREN. THIRTY
SEVEN NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ ARE
WE GET OUR. THANK YOU
GRADUATION AT YOUR COLLEGE
THANK YOU MUCH. TEN ZERO THAT
SELL. MEMBERS WILL GO THROUGH
THE ROLE AGAIN FOR THOSE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE MISSED ANY
VOTES I BELIEVE IT'S JUST MISS
RODRIGUEZ UNLESS SOMEBODY ELSE
HAS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND PATIENCE. ALL
ORDERS NINE. I GOT A LOT MORE
WORK IN A SHOP WITH ITS BILLS
UP AND RUNNING. THANK YOU CAN
OKAY. WHAT'S WITH A MINOR. AND
YOU CAN BEGIN. WHAT ON ON A
CONFIRMED CALENDAR AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HI RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. FOR ADAM. EIGHTY
THREE ZERO ZERO SEVEN.
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOW. BROWN
AB THREE ZERO SEVEN NINE
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT VOTING
VERY GOOD THE NUMBER YOU GET
NINE. YOUR. WITH NO REAL QUICK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK. OKAY
OKAY THANKS. MEMBERS INCLUDE
THE BUSINESS FOR THE DAY A
HEARING IS NOW ADJOURNED.